today's recipes are big on spices herbs
and wonderful aromatics
i've taken my inspiration all the way
from the arabian peninsula to turkey and
north africa and put together a
fantastic middle eastern breakfast lunch
and dinner i absolutely love dishes from
this part of the world so for my
ultimate middle eastern food expect lots
of incredible grilled meats and
vegetables with pulses and delicious
fresh and zingy flavors
first up for breakfast a staple in
middle eastern food filo pastry and i'm
making crispy and fragrant triangles
with luxurious honey yogurt
next it's lunch and my take on a turkish
classic lamb coffees with yogurt and
mint and a vibrant beetroot and chickpea
hummus
delicious
for dinner i dragged my eldest daughter
away from her school books for a lesson
in the kitchen and some father daughter
time i've got revision to be doing don't
worry this is far more important trust
me who needs exams where you can cook
for a living
we're cooking up a taste of arabian
nights with quail and pomegranate
molasses a bright butter bean salad
followed by one of the region's most
loved exports sweet and sticky baklava
wow smells so good
these are my ultimate middle eastern
dishes
breakfast lunch and dinner first up it's
breakfast and my incredibly easy
fragrant crispy filo delicious with a
simple honey yogurt
now
these are beautiful
filler pastry sheets
now it is possible to make it
but
to be honest to try and stretch
the pastry that thin and get it even
it's an absolute nightmare
life's too short to make it at home when
you can buy amazing filo pastry
so
when working with it
always get a nice damp cloth
and just lay the damn cloth over it that
keeps it nice and moist and it stops
the fila pastry from actually drying out
put a pan on to melt your butter
it's the butter that gives the
crispiness
to the filler
pastry if you're ever going to brush or
coat
fill a pastry with butter and make sure
that butter is nicely seasoned
you take
your first
layer lay it onto the board
nice
brush that with your butter
and the nice thing about filler pastry
is that it can be used for savory
and sweet
these are going to have a fragrant
savory flavor with thyme black pepper
and parmesan cheese so no need for salt
lift up the corner
and fold very quickly brush the ends
and just
nip
those ends together
non-stick pan on a little splash of
olive oil fry the pastry for one to two
minutes on each side
so you want them to sort of puff up
the secrets get them quickly you can
smell that cheese in that thyme you're
looking for them to become golden and
crispy simple as that
and then out
smells delicious
and as they sit and cool down
instantly
they become really nice and crispy
the filler goes fantastically well with
thick creamy greek yogurt and a drizzle
of runny honey
there's something quite sort of middle
eastern about the herbs the yogurt and
the honey and the sort of crispy
textures
of the filo pastry an alternative savory
breakfast
when you want a stunning and
sophisticated breakfast that mixes
fragrant herbs and cheese with glorious
honey yogurt this middle eastern treat
hits the spot and it's so simple to make
[Music]
the more you learn about ingredients the
better and the more varied your cooking
will become
now here's a closer look at some i'm
using today
first up i've already used filo pastry
in my breakfast and i'm using it later
for a sweet dessert
made from just flour water salt and oil
it's incredibly fiddly to roll into
tissue thin sheets
so i like to use good chop bought
ready-made filo which makes cooking
middle eastern delicacies like the lemon
baklava i'm making later a breeze
[Music]
quail may seem quintessentially british
but this little game bird originates in
the middle east
they've got a lovely light gamey flavor
and it's quick and easy to cook in the
middle east it's eaten whole or
flattened and grilled over charcoal
i'm marinating mine in pomegranate
molasses and roasting it
it's the magic of the east on a plate
next chickpeas are a staple in middle
eastern cooking
chickpeas either come as flour dried or
ready to go in cans or jars
[Music]
if you're cooking the dried ones from
scratch don't add salt into the finished
cooking
you can also buy them pre-cooked in
either brine or spring water
they're packed with protein and so
versatile whether as a stuffing in a
salad or blended as part of the beetroot
hummus i'm making next
one of the brilliant things about
cooking at home is being able to bring
ingredients and influences from all over
the world right into your very own
kitchen for my ultimate middle eastern
lunch i'm bringing a touch of
mediterranean sunshine into my home in
the grey sky of london
gorgeous grilled lamb copters with my
incredible twist on the middle eastern
classic hummus
first job glorious beetroot hummus
i'm gonna blend and puree the cooked
chickpea
and the beetroot
now
the beetroot gives that pickley
delicious flavor to the hummus
beetroot's in
with the chickpea
a nice seasoning of salt and pepper
a tablespoon of olive oil a tablespoon
of tahini
this is roasted sesame seeds
pounded and mixed with oil
now crushed garlic and toasted cumin
seeds grind then pop into a blender
[Music]
i love that nice dark rich color and you
finish it
with a nice
lemon
slice it in half
take out the seeds
and squeeze the fresh lemon juice at the
end just
wakes up
the acidity in the beetroot but really
cuts the richness of the chickpea and
the lemon juice is pivotal
it really brings the beetroot and the
chickpeas together chickpeas are packed
with protein very dense and it needs
that kind of acidity one more little
blend
lovely
nice
taste
that's delicious homemade beetroot
hummus so tasty and it really is that
easy to make
to finish some toasted cumin seeds and
sumac
now this is delicious it's a sort of
middle eastern spice
and then
some sesame seeds
finish that off
with margarine almost done now for my
koftas pan on onion
nice and finely diced
garlic three nice clothes
squeeze the garlic
over the onions
onions
garlic in
you get a really nice color on them
after that
a nice teaspoon
of chili flakes
beautiful now into our pestle and mortar
with a teaspoon of toasted cumin
give that a little bit of salt in there
helps grind it down that
is such a lovely smell aromatic
exciting
spicy intriguing
once ground to a fine powder sprinkle
your spices into the onion and garlic to
create a wonderful aromatic paste
now for the lamb mince lightly season it
and then add all that wonderful flavor
next for some freshness parsley and mint
roughly chopped and a glug of olive oil
put your hands in there
and give that a really good mix
traditionally you can see
coffees on
little sticks
bbq
skewers and depending on where you are
they have different sort of variations
and shapes and sizes
i much prefer the nice little sort of
almost like little mini
burgers like little mini
sliders but
these can be griddled
these can be
fried in a pan or even cooked on the
barbecue
start by rolling the mix into a golf
ball size then flatten out always
lightly oil your plate
that way when you set them in the fridge
you don't need to be all again they're
going straight into the pan because
they've got oil underneath and all on
top keep your hands lightly oiled
and it helps
to stop the lamb from sticking to your
fingers then pop them into the fridge to
set and firm up before cooking
now you can cook the coffee in a frying
pan on the barbecue or an amazing little
griddle pan
get the plaque really nice and hot
whilst that heats i'm making a yogurt
dip i love
a nice sort of fresh minted yogurt
put fresh mint leaves
salt and a pinch of toasted cumin and
black pepper into a pestle and mortar
to grind as you start to sort of
blend
the mint almost turns into a nice fresh
mint puree
and the smell
out of that
is incredible
add yogurt and i like greek best and a
squeeze of lemon
but look at that now
beautiful now helicopter so they go on
[Music]
one of the biggest problems on cooking
coffer is that they move them too early
and they start to break up but
let them grill
and by grilling them
they'll naturally lift off the bar once
they're charcoaled and so literally two
two and a half minutes each side
now
turn it over
beautiful
the smell is incredible
once browned on both sides they're ready
to serve
on
[Music]
delicious i absolutely love lunches like
this because it's sort of bold food
that's packed full of freshness and
great flavors
these quick and easy minty lamb coffees
served with beetroot hummus are perfect
for a relaxed meal your family and
friends will all want to tuck into
one of the things i love about middle
eastern food is its vibrancy it really
creates a great atmosphere in your
kitchen with lots of color lots of fresh
herbs fruit vegetables nuts honey and
sweet syrups and for my ultimate middle
eastern dinner i'm filling the house
with the fantastic smells of aromatic
cooked meat
[Music]
and helping me in the kitchen to take a
well-earned break from my studies is my
eldest daughter megan
first job at pomegranate marinade for
the quail which have been cut in half
and flattened
so small aren't they small yeah it's
tiny so it's almost like a sort of nice
entrance into eating something slightly
gamey
okay if you give them a nice season for
me salt and pepper
and all spatchcock means is that the
ribcage has been taken out and they're
flattened down and because the bird is
so delicate
it's flattened to cook evenly
and
it really is a nice sort of light gamey
dense chicken flavor
so we're toaster spices when you think
of middle eastern food it's packed with
amazing flavors tablespoon of coriander
a teaspoon
of cumin
and a nice little seasoning
of salt so we toast them now
intensifying the flavor when they start
smoking lightly
that's a nice indication that they're
ready
okay
if you grind away so the best thing
there let's just stand a little closer
today thank you
oh look your tummy's out
i thought it was the quail it was a
little tummy this hand here
keeps it nice and firm
and you grind that into a nice powder
for daddy please
smells so good doesn't it yeah
so to get that in
really go around the outside and that
grinds it up fast
i've gone around and i pressed the
mortar
more times than you kissed boys
squeeze the garlic in next
a little glove
olive oil
okay and i want you to pour
six tablespoons please
so that is
pomegranate molasses so it's like an
aged balsamic vinegar but really reduced
down give that a nice mix up
is it gonna be very sweet dad a little
taste
it's sweet but sour yeah it is
it's so good though no
take
a nice spoon
put it inside the quail
you can even do this
the night before because you pop them in
the fridge let the quail marinate
anywhere from half an hour to overnight
for my ultimate middle eastern dessert
it's got to be baklava
start by melting butter in a pan
chop pistachios in a blender
[Music]
then combine with caster sugar and lemon
zest
[Music]
brush the melted butter around a small
baking tray
place half a sheet of filler pastry on
the base
brush well with melted butter
and sprinkle with a pistachio mix
repeat and press down between layers
you're looking to create
to 35 layers
[Music]
then cut the baklava into bite-sized
rectangles and bake in a preheated oven
for 30-40 minutes
meanwhile
make your delicious citrusy syrup simply
add water to a pan along with caster
sugar
and the zest and juice of a lemon
simmer for seven to ten minutes making
sure the sugar has fully dissolved
now to give the baklava a wonderful
sweetness remove from the oven and
whilst hot pour over the syrup so each
layer is gloriously sticky
leave the picalava to absorb the syrup
for at least 12 hours these delicious
sticky treats will keep for a week but
they're so moorish they'll be gone in a
flash
the quails have marinated now they're
ready to cook nice hot pan
pick up your quail
and skin side down first okay
get all that nice color
and always open them up as well in the
pan
okay we'll get that skin crispy crispy
that's right
smell that pomegranate i can really
smell it smells so good get all that
marinade in there
you know cook with it as well don't
waste it
how long on average does it take to cook
literally
12-15 minutes in the oven
a little touch of water
in
[Music]
bring that up to the
bowl into the oven 180
so 12 to 15 minutes
okay
the final job before serving a herby
butter bean salad to go with my quail in
pomegranate molasses
now
one of the things that i
love about middle eastern salads is the
sort of crunch
and the color as well butter beans
it's gonna be the base of our salad
from there
little radishes and sort of top
and tail them get them like that
and throw them in
there's nothing small and dainty in
there okay yeah so
with the spring onions
nice we're gonna use the greens and the
whites i'm going to slice
along that way this time to get those
nice light shards okay yeah
now
the croutons
are made out of these little pita breads
just slice lengthways in with a salad oh
yes
so this salad is all about texture so
cucumber okay
and take out your seeds
how come you're taking the seeds out it
just makes the salad very watery
it's like a shower okay
cucumber juice delicious i think there
you go yeah you got me going you really
got me going no no no oh yeah
i've got revision to be doing don't
worry this is far more important trust
me who needs exams where you can cook
for a living
you gave me with my exams it's fine it's
fine it's fine be a chef for a living
have a proper job don't talk your things
out like that you'll be thumbless let's
go
now get cucumber in from there
take your nice
vibrant tomatoes slice down
it almost looks like a greek salad as
well little colors it resembles that
that's right and with the celery like
before yeah lengthwise so we need some
mint and parsley
i want you sprinkling it in there
really mix it through the herbs give it
that nice kind of freshness
but i want a bit of a bite in there now
i love pomegranate so just carefully
open that up
and then just dot them on top so we've
got a bit of fruitiness now into the
salad
for crunch simply cut up whole pita
breads fry in a really hot pan with
olive oil into a wonderfully golden
crispy and irresistible
out
into a
sieve
okay
next a sprinkle of sumac
that's a dried fruit from the middle
east the zest of a lemon
and the juice
then a drizzle of olive oil
and last but not least my crunchy pitter
croutons croutons on oh they've gotten
hard oh just lift that up
and mix in your hands there nice and
jump just with finger tips there you go
so you just mix there you go it doesn't
crush anything it doesn't crush anything
but then let's just take
a little bean
wow
is that delicious um
nice
now quail
it's got that really
mmm sort of toasted almost like a sort
of light smells so good barbecue flavor
can't wait to try it
beef
wow
just finely a bit of lemon zest it just
lightens everything up a little bit
and it goes so well with the pomegranate
now just
wow
that'll smell better than any boyfriend
you'll ever have oh my god
i beg to differ
okay good let's go
how delicious is that so delicious
my middle eastern feast of quail with a
pomegranate molasses and butter bean
salad with botlava to follow when dishes
are this aromatic and colorful there's
no wonder that middle eastern food is
always a hit
right tilly mum
dinner
now
look at this i'd like to serve the
cellars oh wow hi holster
till how's the quail it's really good
thank you i love it
how's the salad it's really nice
delicious
there are loads more great home cooking
recipes on my app cook with me you can
find it in the app store good luck
like was it easy to make yeah it was
actually it's very simple and fun
did you make it
[Music]
you're gonna get it tonight